my guest tonight chorus an extremely
talented actor who has starred in
numerous films and TV shows including
third Rock from the Sun daddy's home -
and the crown just to name one one
thousandth of his work now you can see
him in the HBO series Perry Mason which
I'm hooked on please welcome our very
good friend John let's go how are you
Conan I'm great all the better for
seeing you yes I'm uh they say that I'm
the best medicine in these times well
especially with your hair like that I
mean I know it's out of control I
haven't had a haircut in a while and
when I treat it cheers me up know an
action I actually have a haircut on
Saturday just for you Oh
knowing that I was gonna be on t on TV
with you yeah clearly yeah you look very
nice clearly you cared a lot more than I
did
it's so absurd when talking to you John
did to mention just some of your credits
because you've done so much so to say
third Rock or you know or the crown it
feels like what we're not mentioning the
9000 other things you've done to great
acclaim do you what's the project you
think you hear about the most from fans
when you're walking down the street
precoded no one's got a mask on what do
people want to talk to you about well it
could just can be any number of things I
mean because of what you just said I am
this curiosity of an actor who is known
for many different things so you walk
down one block of a crowded Street
something you cannot do anymore and
people will stop me for a whole variety
of things third Rock and the son Dexter
the crown some appearances on the Conan
O'Brien show twenty years ago right
perhaps my most memorable work I ope
even
[Applause]
many people have won Oscars for their
appearances on my show which is a but it
can happen it does you know third Rock
was an interesting role for you because
because you were an alien you were
allowed to as an actor display just
about anything you're able to do you
know what I mean you couldn't you can
have the superpower of showing anything
that John Lithgow can do that must have
been a real kick for you well that's
almost the definition of what was so
special about that project that role and
a big reason why I took it on do you
have a favorite moment where you got to
do something that you'd never get to do
otherwise yes I would say perhaps the
the Irish clog-dancing I did in the
episode where we parodied the Lord of
the dance
we had him for Michael Flatley we were
so determined to take him down because
he was such a smug self-important
artiste and bonny and Terry created this
this thing called the king of the jig
and I and the entire cast of the show
poured out of the theater having just
seen this and in my exhilaration I
started dancing like Michael Flatley and
then everybody did it was it was one of
those electrifying moments on 3rd Rock
which was a show where anything could
happen
just for fans and I know this was a
favorite of people's I remember this
really well we have that clip right now
[Applause]
we come back now delighted that we've
seen it yeah oh my god I I was
transported during the entire how are
you doing during quarantine how are you
as a human being not an alien a human
being
handling quarantine well you know one
aspect of it has been very lovely I've
been alone with my wife and it's been
four months now it's almost as if we've
been making up for all those times in
our like 40-year marriage when her
business or mine have have separated us
she's a professor I'm an actor I've
spent like 30 percent of that time on
location 20 percent on a film set in LA
this was like making up for all that we
just turns out we we realized we were
even better company for each other than
we ever dreamed it was lovely beyond
that I actually had a creative project
that kept me going up until about three
or four weeks ago and that was I wrote
an entire book I I had a book contract
to do a follow-up of my political humor
book who dumpty we came last October
that was a big success my publisher
begged me to do another one in time for
the election I said no no no no I
finally said yes and then I thought oh
my god how am I ever gonna do this I'm
working on a TV series well along comes
a global pandemic the series is
suspended I have nothing to do but eat
sleep and cook okay I'll be able to do
this and I wrote the entire book of 32
poems 110 pages did all the
illustrations and it'll be out on
September 29th in plenty of time for the
election when the first book came out
you appeared on the show and you did a
reading from it and the book was a big
success and I was I was really impressed
with the poetry and what did with the
illustrations really really fantastic
well I got
the conan ball you make New York Times
yes I can do that too I can get you an
Oscar or New York time literally yeah
you live up to me but you know you have
to I can read you from this new one -
great this is called trumpty dumpty
wanted a crown versus for a despotic age
and I want to tell you one thing that
should be very flattering I wanted to
hold up the book here in Peru to show it
and it was sent to us and we're here two
feet there and it arrived at the theater
and someone stole it
oh well that's a fine compliment that
your book was stolen
yeah right from right here at the Largo
theater that we all put it up in make
sure that we prominently display it here
on the screen this is about Bill bar
very much in our recent our attorney
general bill bar yeah I'll show you the
illustration first because when you read
the book this is what you would see
[Laughter]
portrayed bill bar as a frog
there he is outside the Oval Office
standing guard it's called bill bar the
door AG bar that faithful sentry guards
the Oval Office entry though he stays
all legal action you should check
self-satisfaction and a single scandal
more and he'll be frog-marched out the
door that's the short one some of them
are two or three or four pages long but
I thought I'd give you a bomb bomb that
was that's terrific
now do you think it's highly read in the
in the White House when it comes out you
know that you think it's gonna be a big
hit with a screw well I certainly hope
they'll read it because if they'll read
it maybe I'll get a tweet out of him I
mean you know of course it's it's a it's
a book to delight and amuse
rolls never Trump furs Democrats in
anticipation of the election but I'm
counting on a lot of right-wing fanatics
buying it too they'll want to buy it in
order to burn it a lot of us are angry
but as you know when you're in the
comedy business you you're trying to
walk a line of not just being outright
raged you're trying to still remember
that your job is to entertain people and
to milk and to get a smile out of them
and you know and I think that's what you
that's what you've done with this I have
to say Coenen you are a much more
interesting interview subject than I am
on this on in this matter I mean I am
fascinated by the challenge that all of
you are facing all of you late-night
wits and satirist and commentators how
do you I mean how do you feel about that
you asked me how I felt not having an
audience right do you feel when things
are so dire and so difficult and so
enraging when your job is to be funny
well there are times where there are
times recently when things have gotten
so dark especially during the right
after George Floyd's killing that I just
decided you know if someone knows how to
try and make this situation win right
now funny god bless him I don't know how
and I don't even think it didn't feel
appropriate to me so there are times
when I think you just have to be a human
being and when things get really dark
you have to say this is not I'm just
gonna talk about this and I'm going to
talk to people about it and so you
surrender you surrender I think a little
bit the comedic role and then the rest
of the time if you think it's at all
possible you try and do it but is it at
all a relief sometime sometimes it is
but mostly if it's if it's so serious
that you can't even that you can't do
what you I feel like I was put here to
do which is to entertain people and make
them laugh if I can't do that it's you
know it
I think it's at least cathartic to talk
to people and say how do you feel about
this and and we we can have a discussion
even if it's not funny discussion I
think that's one of the rules I mean
Johnny Carson I watched him growing up
and he would have guests on and he
wouldn't go for laughs and I think
that's completely appropriate I think
it's well and you and and a few more of
your of your cohort I mean there are
those moments when things are too grave
to be funny and you think of Letterman
when he addressed the nation when he
first came on the air after 9/11 yeah
you know if you put up had a list of the
ten greatest Letterman moments that
would be right up near the top yep
moments when a funny person just stops
being funny and talks from the heart and
is capable of doing that the real
integrity and authenticity oh that's
that's got a tremendous amount of power
and it's I think it's essential for us
all in a sense that's more comforting
than making people laugh in dark times
yeah I still think I always relieved
when we get back to a situation where I
can be silly again silly is my that's
not that's that I've never seen you be
silly Conan I know I know you're right
occasionally I'll find evidence that I
was occasionally silly you know I didn't
want to mention I love talking about me
and I think what this interview should
really be like I wanted to mention
quickly I absolutely like like I think
all of us I think it's impossible not to
love the show the crown the series the
Crampton and you portrayed Winston
Churchill and we've talked about this
you did a brilliant job and I thought
you really inhabited Churchill and
clearly had to know a lot about him and
kind of become him to do that role if
there was an alternate universe where
Cove it'd hit
and instead of the current occupant of
the White House we had Winston Churchill
how would he handle it I would say if
you could pick anyone in the entire 20th
century who would do the best possible
job facing our current crisis it would
be Churchill it just look at the
evidence of World War two how he faced
World War two
Churchill was an eccentric man he was
very unpredictable he was difficult in
many senses is possible his politics
were sometimes contemptible but but he
would have attacked this crisis like a
dog with a bone he would not have let a
minute pass in his entire day where he
didn't have some other idea for how to
address a problem and to bring the
country together to do it he was exactly
what England needed in 1940 we so needed
that kind of sort of bullheaded
assertiveness we needed someone who
would whom we would all listen to and
trust at this moment we didn't have that
and so things have just gotten worse and
worse and worse and well we won't well I
think what I noticed is that the
Churchill as you portrayed him and as as
he actually was would micromanage he
would he would have figured out how are
we getting these masks he would have
said it is his job of government to save
the people yeah it would have been all
over it if he if Churchill had happened
to also have a chain of hotels and
resorts for example the first thing you
would have done would have been to put
those at the disposal of nursing homes
so that all old people could be isolated
and taken care of in comfort and not
grouped together I mean things like that
he would have thought way way outside
the box
and you know those first few days well I
mean in the months before long months
before there were preparations that had
to be made for this moment when when
Trump and company obliterated that
committee that was all set for pandemic
preparedness that was the first colossal
mistake and the mistakes have just
searched tumbled out ever since yeah I
know we have to be hopeful and reverse
all of them yeah yeah well your book
will help every little bit helps my it's
like pissing into the wind my book but
you know that's what I do for a living
great description of your career pissing
it away I did want to mention I'm
watching Perry Mason and loving it it's
fantastic I mean the cast is absolutely
incredible and it it looks amazing I
mean the art direction
I'm very Mason I feel like I'm in 1931
Los Angeles it's six stories and I love
your character EB EB is this sort of
mentor counterpart to Perry Mason I feel
like you're his he looks up to you
you're his someone who's kind of a
mentor figure to him but you're your
character is interesting to me because I
feel like he's struggling with aging out
is that right that's exactly right and
in the course of it Perry Mason serve
sees his feet of clay it's a fascinating
character I mean look Conan I'm 74 years
old I'm approaching the time in my life
when everyday I will worry about losing
my viability turns out those are all the
roles that are coming my way it's a
wonderful thing to play because it
didn't have its bits it's got a
wonderful humor to it it's got a sadness
to it and it it serves the store
wonderfully because it the the beginning
of this series is an origin story
how did Mason become much attorney well
he becomes an attorney by doing a better
job than his mentor right though and I
also I love the relationship between
your character EB and his assistant
Delos Street
it reminds me a lot of my relationship
with my assistant sona julian violence
plays the part fantastic actress from
england and boy did she get it right
well we have a clip here from Perry
Mason and I think we're going to cut to
that now we're just basically seeing
your character here in action his this
is this is him I think we get a sense of
his character here from this clip great
let's have a look I came to this little
Pueblo about a year before he ascended
to the Supreme Court since that time
Justice Holmes has distinguished himself
as the nation's foremost jurist and Los
Angeles has disgraced itself as a
Gomorrah where truth is bought and sold
like the head of a rutabaga
what are you waving about he just wants
me out of the picture too this is why I
have taken up the cause of Emily Dom's
when a state aims its annihilating power
against a mere individual who will stand
up against it who will defend the
defenseless who will fight for justice
against a heartless expediency this is
what your readers need to know yes of
course something else our readers would
like to know where do you go to eat
you have a night out I am fond of the
French Dip at Philippe's
alright actually see it pretty good
pretty good well let's make sure I get
the the word out thank you so much for
doing this Perry Mason airs Sundays at
9:00 on HBO and it's available to stream
on HBO Max and trumpty dumpty wanted a
crown versus for a despotic age is
available September 29 and it's a
delight it's so good
someone stole our copy high praise
indeed for a book these days wonderful
to see you hopefully next time it's in
person yeah it will be I'm sure and John
I take care of yourself be well and and
stay safe and thanks for continuing to
make such great great stuff it really
ain't much gone and we'll get through
this and you'll help all right thank you
very much take care
great real fun bye bye a bite